hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my flash episode 14 battle royale
video careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet
Loki freaked out for that post-credit
scene at the end never going to think
about big belly burger the same way
again but there's a new round of the
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video so let's go top 10
WTF in comic book Easter eggs there's so
much to talk about normally I say so
levar is the MVP of the episode just in
the way he took Grodd down but we got to
say Ernst 19 flash the accelerated man
MVP is the episode just for the brief
appearance that he was on and that
purple looking lightning hopefully he'll
come back in the future but here we go
for real top 10 flash does valentine's
day pancakes and all so the thing about
this is today at least in the united
states i don't know about worldwide it's
actually National Pancake Day so it was
just a bit of a funny moment of Barry
going way overboard because he has the
abilities of the flash so I got every
single breakfast food you could possibly
imagine just wanting to make it special
they think that they defeated Grodd so
HR has completely decked out starlets
they have that funny moment with
Harrison wells from earth-2 where he
spits in the coffee throw some shade
Loki calls HR a psychopath just being as
grumpy as possible just so you see the
juxtaposition and how different they are
so anytime they're on screen together
it's amazing I feel like we need a
Council of reeds moment where they do an
orphan black episode where it's all just
a bunch of harrison wells from the
multiverse with Tom Cavanagh playing
everybody all trying to solve some
problem at STAR Labs if you don't know
what the Council of reasons is just a
deep cut from the Fantastic Four comics
where mr. fantastic from all the
different universes band together to
solve problems because he's one of if
not the smartest person at any given
time on the earth technically he's not
the smartest but you get the idea and
they even did the same thing on Rick and
Morty called the Council of Riggs but it
just shows you what an amazing actor Tom
Cavanagh is I feel like the other actors
do good jobs when they do earth two
versions themselves like Caitlin's earth
to killer frost was a lot of fun but Tom
Cavanagh is the master of alternate
personalities just as Cisco's bemoaning
the fact that he's going to be alone for
the rest of his life eternally
friendzone and Kaitlyn's like you know
golden glider I think there
something there she was kind of nice
even though I wouldn't let you date her
gypsy jumped through a portal and starts
going to town on team flash just
shutting them down it lets you know how
powerful Cisco is going to get pretty
soon too this is important for later and
this is the second time we've seen her
disable a speedster like basically
blocked their ability to access the
Speed Force so like we saw that giant
WTF post credit scene with Savitt are
they'll be really important for stopping
sabotage so just make a mental note of
all the things that [ __ ] does to shut
down speedsters in this moment but they
throw her in prison in a no short order
or figure out what Grodd did I mean it
was a pretty easy to figure out like she
was sitting there like a total zombie
when he was like you will open the
breach we'll take the army through so
okay very clearly he's mind controlling
her so then they throw to the big reveal
though like where is Grodd we can't find
him boom suddenly he's on the edge of
the city with his army ready to make war
it was a great reveal shot just like
Grodd always one step ahead and it sort
of starts Barry's line of thought where
he starts to get really bummed out about
never being able to make his victory
stick so we'll come back around to that
in a second but number 7 Cisco's new
five-year so because we have so many
geniuses that are back under one roof
now they juice up Cisco's vibe gear but
let him know that it could melt his
brain if he's not careful any time they
bring back some cool invention you have
to wonder when they're going to bring it
back because it's like okay this is very
clearly going to come in handy when we
have a bigger battle later on but it's
all a trap a lot of Star Wars references
in this episode turns out number six
Grodd manipulated Joe West into getting
them here as a distraction so that he
could grab the general always one step
ahead and in this moment they do try to
get [ __ ] back on the team and they have
that big star killer reference so like I
said Star Wars references the Luke
Starkiller reference is just the
original title of Star Wars
it was The Adventures of the star killer
the Star Wars Episode one so it was just
part of George Lucas's original
treatment for the Star Wars movies
before he turned it into a new hope but
in the context of the episode it's just
a funny wink at how things are different
between dimensions like Weird Al is a
philosopher on earth 19 but he does
parody songs on ours
so the real
ut'fo of this like big garage Oh twist
is the e almost has him kill himself I
know a lot of you are like what if Joe's
the person that dies at the end of the
season I'm not expecting that like there
are a couple other more temporary
characters that I think that they'll
kill off and that'll be the way they get
him off the show but they do take you
right to the edge like he was not faking
out he was definitely going to have Joe
kill himself that's how hardcore Grodd
is so it all just feeds into that idea
that Barry feels like none of his
victories are going to stick raw it's
always going to come back bigger and
badder so how does he defeat somebody
number five Barry's moral dilemma this
is like the most classic comic book
story ever hero feels like he's unable
to make his victory stick so maybe the
good thing that will come because he
does a bad thing will justify the bad
thing but in this case it's like the
worst thing you could do killing someone
else which is hardcore against the
Flash's ethos
he even references Oliver Oliver kills
people and he seems like he's okay but
then iris reminds him that no he is
totally not okay he is way messed up and
it said that is the reason that Oliver
very rarely smiled Barry is totally not
that person here's where I think they're
bringing things back around to like the
overarching savat are plot lines the
evil speedsters story so most of the
evil speedsters on the TV show and in
the comics didn't immediately start out
being super evil they were good people
that wanted to do something good but
then for some reason they made the wrong
choice did something bad in the name of
good and it became the slippery slope to
darkness that's kind of a reverse slash
thing where he admires Barry Allen he's
like a Barry Allen fanboy before he
became the reverse-flash but then he
finds out that he's going to become a
villain in the future so it puts them on
the slippery slope to becoming evil and
he becomes the reverse-flash over time
but he didn't start out that way so they
might also do the same thing for sabit
are the first person to get speed he
probably didn't start out being super
evil something happened that caused him
to do something bad then eventually over
time he became the villain that we see
on the show today so this was like a
really big plot point even though it
seemed like they brushed over it like
Barry's like okay I'm not going to kill
anybody but I think this moral lesson
will come back in the future so number
four the flash disc
arms the nukes at SuperSpeed with his
decoding abilities it's just a
brute-force hack just gotta keep going
keep going I thought they were going to
go a different direction with this
because the definition of insanity is
doing the exact same thing over and over
expecting a different result
but in reality I think it's just them
telling Barry not to quit like don't
quit just keep going don't give up even
though it looks like everything's lost
so just a fun way to show off casual use
of Speed Force powers but number two
garage versus Sola bar Battle Royale
so I feel like they tip the hat to this
in the first part of the episode they do
a really good job of setting up big
twists that are going to be happening
later on where Grodd told Barry the
whole reason that he needed him is
because he wasn't powerful enough
himself to stop so levar I can't beat
him in a fight so after last week's
episode when they left so levar alive
it's like okay well very clearly they're
going to need him to stop Grodd because
Barry can't stop Grodd by himself so
anytime something like that happens just
remember it for a future episode now
this was like a two-parter so you had to
know that he was going to come back just
because they left him hanging but like
where did soul of our go he was actually
a pretty big character but this is the
same thing with the sabot our plotline -
anytime something really big happens or
the flash learned some new trick it
usually comes back later but there was
no way that they were going to be able
to defeat the gorilla army by themselves
for a minute I did wonder if earth 19
flash was going to come help them out
but even with like four speedsters it
still probably wouldn't have worked and
they don't have Jay Garrick either so
speaking of which I've also talked about
the Earth's 19 flash a couple times this
is a new actor it's not Eddie it's not
Robbie Amell it's not someone we've seen
before but he's another Earth's 19
person like [ __ ] who tracks down
breachers because flashes can travel
between dimensions just like gypsy can
so think of him as the Red Baron version
of the flash just because from the
comics the place where he comes from
their earth is stuck in like World War 1
era so that's why everybody looks like
they're in World War 1 clothing but
really cool and it was cool that he had
a different color lightning it just
shows you that we'll see more of this
throughout the season maybe we'll see
some more versions of the flash but the
rest of the season is mostly going to be
dedicated to the savat our plot line so
we'll see but they tease them so he's
got to come back at some point but the
real big thing here that got me
really crazy about next season or even
later this season they don't have to
wait that long is that now Grodd is in
Argos on earth one with Lila who else is
in Argos right now black siren so they
are building themselves a new Suicide
Squad what would you guys think about
the idea of a Grodd lead Suicide Squad
would that not be the craziest thing
ever it would be amazing they could do
that for the four night crossover next
year where Grodd assembles like a crazy
version of the Suicide Squad and even
prometheus if Oliver defeats them by the
end of the season they could throw him
in Argus two so you have prometheus
Grodd black siren they're basically
building themselves and in Justice
Society so freaked out about that but
who knows they might choose not to
pursue that but they just have a bunch
of ace cards to play that they're
sticking in their back pockets for the
future so at any given time any of those
people and Argus could break out and do
something crazy
so speaking of crazy number one Barry
proposes to Iris will freak out about
that in a second but the other part is
that Wally sees avatar so there's just
so much that happened in the final
moments one they are super fast going to
Barry and iris getting married who knows
if that'll stick because she's going to
die at the end of the season or is she I
mean really do we actually think that
they're going to kill Candice Patton off
the show there's no way they're going to
do that there'll be some big twists but
that doesn't necessarily mean that
they'll get married at the end of this
season so they might just be engaged for
like the next three seasons of the show
they're just telling you that they're
going to get married at some point in
the future in the comics there's a big
Easter egg because this avatar storyline
picks up with Wally West thinking about
proposing to Linda Park like he's trying
to figure it out they really didn't
actually get those characters married
till like way way later though it was
way after The Saboteur Ark but the other
part Wally's seeing Savitt are so he
thinks that he saw him for real but
Barry thinks that he's hallucinating him
so sabotage says I have my way to get
back now so Wally seems like he's going
to be a big weakness for the team so
everybody is going to be freaking out
about that next week
so everybody freaked out about that in
the comics you never think about big
belly burger again the same way while
he's going to have seizures every time
somebody mentions big belly burger but
what's going to happen later tonight is
a brand new guardians of the galaxy
trailer this post
so I'll get that up as fast as possible
like it's literally coming in the next
hours I'm posting this so what I'll do
is tomorrow morning I'll do flash
trailer there's no legends of tomorrow
episode but there is an arrow episode
and there's no agents of shield or
anything like that
and if you guys are wondering about
Legion I'm actually not going to do
another Legion video till after the
finale airs which is episode 8 so I'll
just try to remind people in the next
Marvel videos that I post about that so
congratulations to last week's flash
ring giveaway winner Rafa Baker please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there was a new round in this
video and I also have a Guardians
giveaway that's going on so I'll
announce the winner when I post that
Guardians trailer so coming up in a
little bit while you wait for that you
can click here to learn all about next
year's four-night crossover and you can
click here for that guardians of the
galaxy trailer thank you so much for
watching what's that bot I'll see you
guys tonight
you